Planet Traveler introduces the Space Case 1,...
...the world's most advanced smart suitcase.
When we designed the case, we wanted to give you the ultimate security.
That's why we've added a biometric lock with fingerprint recognition...
...that grants you access to opening or closing your suitcase...
...simply with the touch of your finger or through the app.
Space Case 1 is linked to a multifunctional smartphone app.
The global tracker provides real-time tracking...
...and maintains a record of your case's location throughout the world.
You never need worry about overweight fees.
Our digital self scale weighs your suitcase even without you lifting the case.
Incredible innovation and design has led us to build the sensors into the wheels,...
...so you are hands-free and the weight is visible on your Planet Traveler app.